I'm gonna talk about this right away
could I get into the kind of shape that
you're in is that even possible what the
hell are you doing are you doing it
every day are you eating a special food
well thank you for noticing how can you
not notice that's insanity and it might
be a long road it would be a long road
but generally there's no secret to it
you just have to stop eating all of the
things you want yes anything that tastes
good and exercise every day till you've
lost the will to live I'm sick of it I'm
sorry I'm giving serious consideration
to hanging up the six-pack yeah I'm
retiring yeah let me tell you at six now
let me tell you it's really nice on the
other side I'll tell you scum I have a
one cause I have an AB back here that's
floating south rapidly uh okay let's
talk about this guy Ritchie what's
incredible about this is it's a period
piece but it feels like Guy Ritchie has
managed to give it his style which you
know in some ways is very modern do you
understand that smite Akon it is that he
has this ability to do a piece that's
taking place hundreds and hundreds of
years ago but you feel like it's that
contemporary Guy Ritchie feel yeah I
mean I think that's one of the I think
that's the it it's base concept what's
so fantastic about this which is this is
one of the oldest stories I mean people
have been telling the King Arthur story
for fifteen hundred years at this point
which is because it's very very good but
if you're going to retell the story you
need to make it fresh and original and
unique and I just had a really exciting
take on how to do that I mean the world
creation as you can see in this thing is
massive and he's created this epic
complex worlds with a huge element of
magical realism but then in the center
of it you have the classic Guy Ritchie
cheeky loveable lads you know sweet
talking fast punchin loveable rogues
that guide you through this and you know
take on this unlikely task unlikely for
them because they're basically just a
bunch of degenerates that they are the
ones that have been sort of chosen to
come and lead
the country and protect it from the evil
foe you know what's interesting too is
that the story starts out when you are
not King which i think is he so you get
to actually see you make this transition
from a more humble place but I think if
I think from from a standpoint of
building a character that would be kind
of cool yeah absolutely I mean you meet
him in he's a pimp
now I'm joking he's not I I actually and
now I need to make this clear he's
definitely not a pimp he just lives in a
brothel but he you know that was one of
the things that guy was so specific on
it we've seen the version of King Arthur
before where he's the nobleman who goes
on the noble quest to become the noble
King and we thought that's great but it
doesn't feel very fresh and we've seen
it before so the sort of the genesis of
this character is in in this incarnation
is he's grown up in abject poverty but
he's a survivor so to put that in a
modern context we decided to make him
like a street kid or I say we that was
rather grand of me a guy and the
producers and Joby the writer and
everyone made that decision I just got
paid later to come in yeah chillingly
honest but yeah I mean so we meet him
and he's this sort of street guy who is
actually doing pretty well for himself
and so when the call to action comes in
this unlikely destiny gets presented to
him his reaction is you know actually
you can keep it because I'm doing very
well for myself as it is thank you very
much but then of course nothing's that
simple and he has to he gets convinced
that it's you know it's a destiny he
can't deny and he has to go off and you
know save the day alright we have time
for questions I believe and let's see we
got here I was just uh there we go
Oh fresh from his role on Hamilton yeah
you know what I was gonna wear just that
today I'm so glad I didn't I don't we
look like a couple of [ __ ]
I I am not nearly masculine enough to be
in the same room as you in this outfit
can I just stop it
you look handsome no the first role that
I ever played onstage in third grade was
young Arthur in a production of Camelot
so you can't tell looking at me but I
wanted to know how you prepared for such
a legendary iconic role I honestly tried
not to think about it you can really
psych yourself out and taking on this
the perceived significance of a role and
so the mandate here was to invent
something fresh and original and new and
so I just I took the lead from guy and
Lionel will grow my producer and enjoy
be who wrote the script you know with
what they were going for and tried to
understand that and then just inject as
much of my own flavor into it as
possible so I really didn't take on the
sort of her historic significance of the
role because I thought if I did I would
just be afraid to get out of bed in the
morning all right well that is the time
we have I want to thank you so much
let's get there sure that is it oh yeah
it was I'm told I do as I'm told
they put a Warner Brothers chip in my
brain and I do was on different old
you